well here's a stunner jason whitton has
ended his one-year retirement and
one-year stint at espn and has decided
to return
to the dallas cowboys is this
something's going to spread now are you
getting any ideas are you going to
unretire and go back and play football
no definitely not i'm not a hall of fame
caliber player never was so no i'm
you're stuck with me if you're trying to
get me out the door i'm not doing it
basically yeah yeah sorry here i'm here
with you big guy um so
one to ten how surprised were you by
that news uh pretty shocked i gotta say
like that was about an eight or a nine
on the richter scale there i just was
not expecting i thought people here and
you know our nbc staff were joking when
i first heard it now i had heard the
rumors and the cowboys can deny it all
they want but i know from some pretty
credible sources that the talk of asking
him to come back and play last year
during the middle of the season was very
real and obviously he had the big job at
espn but i guess my big question mike is
you know is there something coming at
espn that he knew about that leads him
to go to football or did he just get the
itch and want to go back to football i i
think that it's a combination maybe of
coming back to play football
of getting out of an awkward spot where
he knows and i think he's sufficiently
self-aware that he knows right
he's not suited for that job i'm saying
that as politely as i said right but
that was the common theme and that would
be that would be torture to be trying
your best every week and it just doesn't
work and you're constantly being berated
and criticized and lampooned yeah you
want you want a nice little escape patch
and the perfect one is to go back and
play football and when you look at what
the cowboys have going on with amari
cooper there you know a guy that they
really hadn't had with that skill set
since what terrell owens yeah right
right what's the best receiver they've
had since to who could stretch the field
and make it easier for jason whitten to
do his thing they have the need at pass
catching tight end jason garrett's backs
against the wall steven jones said so
himself so the planets lined up
perfectly for kind of like let's load
the cannon one time and i have a feeling
it's gonna be a short time on retirement
for uh for whitten but come back and
help garrett keep his job and and this
is the perfect way to do it he he looked
like he stayed in shape throughout the
season and i mean i don't know that but
he did i mean anytime they showed a shot
of him in the booth i mean he had his
tight suit on and he looked good i would
think that he is that kind of guy that
hasn't let his body get too far out of
shape uh and to your point yes there's
certainly a spot for him on that
football team he's loved for his
leadership his smarts you know i do
think he can help out a dak prescott um
it's a great example too of like if
you're ever a player and there's just if
you think you should still play you play
until you just can't stand it anymore
what else are you gonna go do after i
think that's why you see the bret bars
and things like this happen at times
because at some point you come to the
realization nothing can substitute that
adrenaline and everything that you get
from a locker room and running out on
the field every sunday that was a story
that brett favre told once
after hearing your dad on the radio
exactly say how many i only play so much
play until they rip the uniform off of
you yes right so whitten comes back and
plays and plays until they rip the
uniform off of him hopefully for him
because it will help the cowboys
especially when they have between
ezekiel elliott amari cooper dak
prescott improving there's an
opportunity there for when you don't
have to be able to run
fast like you did and not that it ever
did run fast you know he gets to the
spot he knows the system he knows where
the ball is going to be he makes the
catch and he does what he can with it
and that's just another reliable target
that you have in an offense that isn't
as creative and diverse as it needs to
be but he definitely makes them better
than they were without and we definitely
know he's going to the cowboys or she's
going to stay at the cavaliers
okay that's awesome he's so close with
jason garrett sure and and and he's such
an iconic figure and look if he wants to
get back into broadcasting after a year
or two maybe he'd be better off
with fox or cbs in like the third or
fourth tier and get more reps workers
you're on a big spot when you have one
of those prime time games and it's
really hard to learn the craft the way
you need to and no one's ever going to
agree if if you are getting better now
it's already baked in and you know what
who knows he may go
he may go 10 years at fox or cbs and
then go back to prime time and those old
narratives are going to lock in again
but i think that it makes sense for the
cowboys it makes sense for him it does
and espn you know what do they do now do
they go with joe tessa tour and booger
mcfarland is the only two or is the
opening now for greg olsen
it sounds like they were trying to make
a push for greg olson so i will be
interested to see who fills that void
and how espn handles kurt warner was not
bashful last year about wanting that
spot so espn has an opportunity here if
it chooses to take advantage of it to
add somebody yeah definitely don't get
any ideas about that either no no well
no i'm not i'm here i'm locked up you
signed the contract you're trying to get
me out of here no no no no no no
yeah you quit squeezing my leg and i'll
quit trying to get you out of here no
that's not happening nope not a deal
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports